[Musique]
après je suis à fond tu appelles ça des
cuisses de mandarine ouais
moi c'est joli les cuisses
donc j'ai repris l'expression
et qui puisse demander
ils sont très énervés
du 9 3 tu es pas bien quoi enfin non
mais là pour le coup en fait ça se
trouve c'est vraiment une expression
débile que j'ai sorti mais c'est parce
que 40 ans j'appelle ça comme ça quoi en
fait donc
d'abord il décide de faire un peu de
roisser 5 de monter tes pions
qui veulent bouffer peut-être il veut
gagner le pion à 4 mais bon parce qu'il
fait c'est quand même pas idiot mais
peut-être je peux prendre 2 B passer le
fond à 5 te mettre en B4 faire un truc
un jour un truc vite fait mais bon
là en fait juste tu vas souffrir alors
je sais pas ça se trouve ça va tenir
mais peut-être qu'il pense qu'il va
tenir ça
pour créer un pion passé ailleurs
ouais mais pour le moment c'est pas un
peu plus l'autre côté Magnus quand même
mais il a plus de temps et il
pleutritablement
ouais c'est une décision de reprendre de
faire ces cinq évidemment tu as pas
hyper envie tu aurais voulu gagner
différemment
de merde arrête elle veut prendre B5
peut-être mais bon il veut temporiser il
veut gagner du temps je pense déjà
pour le Bullet ah bah ouais mais bon il
s'en sort bien parce que ça se passe en
Suisse pas forcément et jusque là non
mais ça pourrait ouais
en fait enfin si je pouvais revenir je
pense ce serait normal le grand Suisse
en Suisse quoi il a fait un peu de la
merde non on bouffe donc
tu as un genre de
[Musique]
c'est compliqué je comprends l'ordi il
faut faire caca
faut l'évaluer
des trucs sur B2 c'est compliqué
tu menaces
G7 tu défends ton Kiri tu n'asses 7
à côté noir et puis bah là tu vas plus
sur le Carlson plus là mais tu vois ce
qui se passe de côté c'est pas
constamment brouillard et que tu
t'arrêtes à 50 % de l'échiquier
[Musique]
mais ça m'amusait mais bon normalement
c'est vite et tu as fait un peu de t'as
fait un peu de chasse non c'est quoi tu
as un canard c'est ça
il fait quoi le canard il bloque en fait
il bloque la case tu le poses quand tu
veux ou tu dois à chaque coup tu le
changes de place
exactement et ça fait trois
il est pas bien Magnus bon mais cette
partie elle suit le cours des autres en
fait c'est à dire qu'il se passe pas
grand chose et on arrive là ils ont
moins de 30 secondes ça va s'animer mais
Caro défense super bien fait du cavalier
8 ouais
[Musique]
il aurait pu la jouer un petit peu
mieux mais bon après il est en gestion
aussi frais fera pas trop gérer contre
Magnus il faut prendre les points quand
l'opportunité
il a l'air tellement bien il carou
et puis tu vas pouvoir viser la case F6
en fait il le défonce mais genre il y a
une énorme différence de niveau entre
les deux
ouais peut-être que
c'est ça
il a l'air très heureux
quand même il a pas été bien quand il
lui a joué il voulait plus voir ce fou
aussi c'était nous faire des misères
c'est bien joué le tour des un
ça c'est tombé
ça fait beaucoup de tomber quand même
c'est déjà c'est le troisième c'est le
troisième tombée déjà
en fait mais après il tombe pas dans les
positions il est mieux non plus hein
écoute ça commence à faire l'amour là le
score hein il a pas l'air d'être bien et
il Carole là c'est en train de le faire
marrer il a l'air d'être tellement
heureux et il commence à danser assez
Terri il commence à être insupportable
fais attention tu as tué la peau de du
saumon
ça peut vite tourner ça
je crois que c'est fini bah là il fait
des yathansaki ça y est il regarde hyper
bizarrement il fait 4 là il fait 40
millions de grimaces genre en mode
est-ce que Carlson est complètement con
oh mais c'est terrible en fait oh il se
fout de sa gueule je te jure il est en
train de se [ __ ] de sa gueule de
regarder de reculer de l'écran genre
mais il est complètement nul et ça il
refait encore une grimace genre en mode
est-ce que le mec il va être mon con
ouais ça y est il hallucine genre j'ai
rarement ouais mais c'est il fait
vraiment une tête genre j'ai rarement vu
un mec aussi nul de ma vie c'est
terrible il se fout de sa gueule
littéralement au premier degré
oh les grimaces qu'il est en train de
lui faire genre en mode mais ce qui
s'est joué quoi
il est en train
là en gros ce qui vient de faire c'est
enfin là il vient juste de l'humilier
avec Kadri masque quoi c'est
exceptionnel
Dame des trois dame de
et ça gagne autant en fait toutes les
parties sont gagnées au temps ça
n'abandonne pas ici
de la jouer mais oui il va pas il va pas
réussir à faire grand-chose
magnifique ouais ça y est il attend
quand même non mais j'en peux plus en
fait c'est tellement du foutage de
gueule non stop ah il est très heureux
il se voit son petit thé failli là quoi
je te chie dessus regarde c'est pas
magnifique en fait après ça vaut mieux
le faire derrière son ordi derrière une
caméra quand même je crois qu'il fait ça
contre femme en partie réelle
non je crois que ça se passe pas très
bien non malheureusement je pourrais
rien faire mais je serais pas très
content mais bon aujourd'hui ils sont
blesse tu taper sur la gueule et qu'on
met pas parti perdu je pense ça serait
mérité quoi mais là en fait là en fait
pour le coup il a raison de faire enfin
je sais pas ce qu'il fait je vois pas la
cam mais de pas jouer d'attendre ça j'ai
aucun reproche là dessus
le cinéma quoi c'est du talon je suis
fermes les yeux là il refait des grives
à deux partout enfin c'est mais c'est
vrai qu'il est tellement content de pas
perdre tu veux dire qu'il est nul c'est
bon il y a pas qu'il s'est cadavre
tu touches la dame dans ma 6 forcée fou
c'est ça tout prend à 5h
après c'est un peu dangereux mais bon
priori pourquoi pas mais là il y a pas
accueil C4 et même idée
quand même
ah là il y avait E4 attaqué mais en fait
tu vas te le prendre ce [ __ ] de
français cette fin je vais au bout d'un
moment
pardon désolé mais tout à l'heure je
pense ça marche juste avant
du monde d'échec mesdames et messieurs
c'est pas de bol tiens regarde alors dis
montre un truc super ok si Magnus trouve
cavalier B5 puis on prend B5 tu reprends
c'est ça dame français 7 dame prend des
5 fourchettes ok largement trouvable
pour un mec du calibre de Magnus
y penser ok en fait il écoute le stream
ok ça ça peut le relancer en face c'est
préparé quoi normalement c'est Ninine
qui a joué du monde donc ça a dû
travailler un peu le truc
il a l'air de connaître ça c'est sûr
au moins il pourra jouer sa pendule quoi
que ça va être longtemps à gagner si ça
gagne de viande plus c'est bon
que je penses tu bouffes
et
pourquoi il a abandonné
peut-être en tout cas bien joué Magnus
qui revient c'est pas pas très rassurant
mais bon la position est encore correcte
ok bon faut changer j'imagine F4
non mais là il joue juste mal
mais je crois qu'il arrive pas à
calculer en fait j'en sais rien c'est
étonnant et son fossés ça des
symptomatiques parce que je le vois pas
faire des
couilles pareil ouais
en fait son placement de pièces c'est
bon c'est du Magnus quoi
bon ben écoute finalement
peut faire des machins là-bas
oh oups et ça abandonne direct pour les
carreaux ça commence à suer côté
américain
[Musique]
si vous l'avez vu monter c'est que il y
avait il y avait quelque chose de très
fort mais qui était quasi introuvable
un peu vide enfin qui maintenant du coup
attaque plus rien
mais bon il va falloir terminer ça et
encore placé une tactique ok on peut
avoir la même avec le pion H3 quoi on
peut voir exactement la même avec le
pion H3 mais bon ça menace tout prend
des cinq et qui est prend ses 6 Fab trop
mal en fait tu as vraiment l'impression
qu'il va aucune tactique mais que son
placement de pièces est exceptionnel
ça fait mal quand même
parce que je pense que la finale elle
est trop facile et là il va aller faire
dame prangis
ouais
quand même je sais pas si la raison ou
pas parce que dans il reste 6 minutes
encore
H2 et Damas 8 un truc comme ça
[Musique]
pas sur une belle partie mais un peu à
l'image du match finalement et c'est
terminé ado ouais ouais j'ai le vrai
chrono
ça doit être complètement gagnant à il
reste 50 secondes
ça se joue trois ou quatre secondes
il reste 41 secondes
qui va pouvoir jouer la montre jusqu'au
bout et qui remporte ce speechess une
dernière partie vraiment à l'image de
tout le match au final Fab ça c'est
jamais vraiment emballé ni dans le jeu
ni dans l'attitude ni nulle part en fait
c'est comme ça
[Musique]